[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 106 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am mock Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick how you doing
Melanie hi Mark I'm doing good how are
you doing I'm good you know here in San
Francisco where are you I'm in Los
Angeles I'm attending nips this week
which is the neural information
processing summit very nice very nice
getting some nice sunny weather I hope
yes definitely warm and sunny this
wonderful holiday season great very very
on theme wonderful I'm very used to a
warm to Samba being from Australia I was
gonna say it's probably familiar right
yeah exactly how is it for you doing
Christmas without the warmth now like
what is that like
December's barbecue season I don't
understand why it would be any different
and you could still barbecue it's not
like you really can't it's true it's
true anyway we should go and get to the
meat of what we are really here to talk
about which is the New York Times
interview that was with deep Kapadia and
JP Robinson they come to us to talked
about how New York Times is using TCP
and deep Kapadia is the executive
director of engineering while JP
Robinson is the principal software
engineer of course after this interview
we're going to touch on a question of
the week which is about mark you want to
set that up yeah so we're gonna have a
chat about best practices for securing
your communities engine cluster and the
containers that run upon them and of
course before we do all of that we'll
get to one of the cool things of the
week
awesome so cool things of the week we
have a lot of kubernetes stuff and
container stuff I will start with my
favorite one because cheaper is good we
are cutting the cluster management fees
on Google communities engine so if
you've ever used gke on us before you
may know that previously 6 plus nodes if
you had more than 6 nodes running on gke
it was 15 cents an hour now effective
immediately actually effective as before
this podcast came out zeroes that's a
good thing
constant reduction lots of reduction yep
it's really that's it very simple and
another thing for the week that we
wanted to mention is that GCP is going
to be available in hong kong's in 2018
yeah so if you
in that region 2018 is gonna be a good
year definitely a region for you or do
some late and say all the time last
thing last thing there's a really cool
article about introducing an easy way to
deploy containers on Google compute
engine I like this one because sometimes
you're like oh I have a container maybe
you found something on duck our hub that
you like like maybe you want to run
Redis or or some sort of WordPress
instance or who knows what right but
it's on docker hub as an image but
you're like kubernetes that seems like a
lot of work I just want to run this on a
single VM sitting somewhere or maybe a
giving a group but like I just want
something simple now you can basically
go over to GCE compute engine and say
hey I'd like to create an instance and
here's the container I want you to run
on it boom done next that's really cool
and you can tie that in to manage
instance groups to an order scaling if
you need to but I really think it's kind
of nice just to have this really simple
thing where you're like oh I just need
to run an instance of you know Redis or
something like that and then it's just
very simple to set up with something out
of hub docker com all right so let's go
ahead and get started with the interview
excellent let's go talk to our friends
at New York Times today I am extra
excited I'm always excited to have two
wonderful people here joining us today
deep Kapadia and jb robinson JP robinson
I should say both from the New York
Times thank you so much for joining us
today here to talk about basically
everything you do with GCP and new york
times JP how are you doing wonderful
thanks good deep how are you doing today
excellent thank you so much excellent
yeah thanks again for for agreeing to
join us on the podcast today to talk
about everything you do GCP at the New
York Times before we get stuck into that
and I'm super excited to do that why
don't you tell us a little about who you
are and what you do deep why don't you
go first yeah so I'm the director of
engineering I run our infrastructure and
operations teams and also our test
automation team which is something I
picked up along the way at at some point
and my teams are mostly responsible for
pretty much managing all of our cloud
infrastructure tooling which includes
the Google cloud platform go what about
the JB I am a principal software
engineer really I own and maintain all
of our internal and open source
libraries and packages when it comes to
the go programming language and I also
lead
back in development for our games team
oh cool so for the crossword and all the
fun toys yeah we used that as a cool
thing of the week not that long ago when
you announced you wrote a blog post on
how you moved the crossword to App
Engine and go that was a really good
blog post not only because it was about
go alright so okay so let's let's talk
high level first I'm guessing probably
deep is the best question for this so
New York Times isn't this a paper
publication like what do you actually do
on the Internet's oh that's that's an
interesting one so yes we we started out
as a paper publication in 1851 but since
then we've embraced other ways of
telling stories one of them being
telling stories online we in fact
launched our first website believe it or
not in 1996 before most people had a
website we've had an online presence for
a long time and along the way we've sort
of transformed the way we tell stories
like we're doing a lot of publications
just for consumption online so we we
have a huge video production team we
also have a daily podcast called the
daily we also have a virtual reality app
if you have an Android or iOS phone you
can download it from the App Store's so
there's there's a lot of things we've
sort of experimented with along the way
but most importantly we have our website
which is fairly well trafficked we get
about I think our homepage used to get
about like 50 million hits a day I don't
know what the latest number is at this
point and then JP has all his games apps
that he can tell you guys about um so
yeah beyond you know just servicing up
the news and in all of our news products
associated with that we have had
historically along with the website our
crossword is a digital offering and
we've a big push from that when it comes
to technology is that not only are we
serving up the crossword we allow you to
play the crossword on one device and
then we try to seamlessly sync it to all
of your devices that may be logged in
yes
so yeah it's a lot of stuff on top of
that you know all these products and
services also have a layer of
personalization built in so there's
obviously a lot of
knology back in all of that fun stuff
and we're constantly trying to come up
with new ways of like repurposing ours
content right we we've always had
recipes and are in our management system
but at one point we decided like you
know how about we build a cooking app
where people can like have annotations
on their recipes and actually share
their recipes with each other etc so
somewhere along the line we created a
new products division which was building
all these experiments and sort of trying
to see if we could prioritize them as it
stands now we are cooking app has its
own own stream of revenue it's available
on the App Store and like you know
people you can just buy a subscription
to it so there's there's definitely lots
of lots of different things cool so
while you were describing all of the
cool things to do I actually went
through the Internet Archive and I found
a screenshot of your webpage on November
12 1996 and I can say yeah I gotta say
I'm very happy that we've evolved very
good webpage I've put a link in the show
notes it's it's actually worth seeing it
back then and now again fantastic it is
yeah it truly was just a single gift
that's all we put up yeah it was a gift
it's anyway since you've talked a little
bit about all of the cool things you do
on the New York Times but our audience
is you know like we are into technical
details tell us a little bit about how
you do this like you we know you're
using App Engine for some of the things
do you use App Engine for everything how
does this work no actually we don't use
App Engine for everything so I mean
we're in a bit of a transition right now
so you know as I said like you know we
we've had a website since since a while
now so at some point like our operations
became large enough for us to sort of
consider like having our own data
centers so we run we were running in our
co-located data centers like we have one
on the East Coast one on the west coast
and a few peripheral ones here and there
we have one in our building in Manhattan
which is quite expensive real estate for
a data center so we've largely been
running applications in our own data
center
that like you know with a layer of
virtualization on top of the bare metal
that we were running about six years ago
I think we decided to start looking at
like this this cloud thing that people
were talking about Soho so we started
like building some apps in in the Amazon
Cloud but you know one of the things we
tried to do was pretty much replicate
what we're doing in our data centers in
the cloud which was probably not the
most ideal way to go about it so what
we're trying to at some point we'd sort
of decided we needed better abstractions
to build our applications granted like
you know they were largely news and
media organizations so I mean technology
isn't quiet our forte even though
they're pretty good at it we feel that
like you know we want to be building
more applications and less
infrastructure so that's that prompted
us to go and like you know evaluate what
we're doing and at some point we decided
that we want to move entirely to the
cloud so that's where Google comes in
and you know for some of the
applications it seemed like App Engine
was a really good fit especially you
know JP started looking at the App
Engine sometime last year and he found
it a very good fit for some of some of
the applications he was building but on
the whole like when we look at some of
the applications we have you know a lot
of those could be containerized fairly
easily so Google also provided us with a
very good abstraction to deploy
containers which was Google container
engine or gke
and you know it gives us all the
benefits of running in kubernetes
without actually having to run
kubernetes ourselves so but both App
Engine and GK together were a bit of a
game changer for us on the application
development side and as I said like you
know we were running our own data
centers we also had this large Hadoop
cluster that we were doing for all sorts
of data processing and like you know
data analysis at some point like our
data team decided to try out bigquery
like they were completely blown away
with with all the features it had and
like you know how with the ease of use
so bigquery was sort of like the gateway
drug for us to start looking at other
Google abstractions and then that led to
us using using App Engine and kubernetes
yeah we've heard that many times people
try bigquery
that the like oh oh wow yeah that's cool
that's cool
so I'm I'm actually kind of curious they
kind of probably dig a little deeper
App Engine communities this is a common
thing that I hear from a lot of people
how do you end up choosing which piece
goes on which platform at this point we
don't so in the sense that you know like
we sort of give people the option and
say like figure out what works for you
the best like what my team did was we
provided our users with a consistent way
to deploy on both App Engine as well as
kubernetes we use a CI tool called drone
and we host drone internally and we
built a couple of plugins that allow us
to deploy the code on GK or App Engine
and both those plugins seem to work for
the most part like of course like you
know there's definitely a people are
always asking for more features and that
kind of stuff and like for the pipeline
to be more and more fancy people want to
do all sorts of blue-green deploys and
and things like that but for the most
part it's it seems to work if you want
to get your code from your laptop to App
Engine or GK and then they decide what
what what works best for them typically
if it's a go application I often see JP
sort of mm up again and like giving them
the spiel about all the benefits of
going on App Engine standard etc etc and
he can tell you more about that but
that's that's that's typically how how
things have been working so far Jaime do
you want to weigh in sure so yeah I mean
it really comes down to you know what's
the basic thing you're building
oftentimes for us it's just a simple API
or something like that I need to store
some data and retrieve it later that
kind of stuff and a lot of times it
really just comes down to App Engine and
data store is really enough I find that
we really we still make GK an option in
case you need to do something crazy or
something that's not necessarily API
service-oriented like even for from my
work sometimes like I have a process
that just needs to generate PDFs I can't
really do that in App Engine so I just
have something listening to pub/sub
generating PDFs and then spitting them
back on pub/sub so it's really like if
it's something basic something simple
that you can build in like a day a lot
of times I'll just point people to App
Engine and they don't have to worry
about anything beyond the product
and for kubernetes is if you want to get
crazy cool I care about the developer
experience you told us a little bit
about the drone plugins that you use
that by the way we also used as a cool
thing of the week long time ago do you
seem to show up a lot jack is there open
source and we love open source could you
tell us it'll be more about how does it
look like when you are actually testing
do you have a QA environment different
to the appengine
like do you have different append
projects how does how do you manage all
of this though from an app App Engine
perspective we generally have a project
per environment I've got one for like
our staging and one for production and
one for like our sandbox or lab or
whatever you want to call it and we do
like it's just a normal get flow you
know you'll check in a feature branch
once that gets blessed on to our
development branch it will get pushed
out to one environment once it's merged
in the master will go to the stage and
environment and then we will tag the
repo with a release and that will kick
off a production deployment so it's
pretty straightforward and we it's very
similar for gke or App Engine really
just kind of get oriented and kind of
event-driven
what JP said as we mentioned before you
open source the plugins for drone so I'm
curious as an organization is like open
source something that's important to you
or as it just been like you thought
things might be useful for other people
what was the what was the story with
that both we definitely want to be a
part of the open source community but at
the same time we also want to be using
tools that can be supported widely so
that was one of the very big reasons for
us to sort of look at drone in the first
place and then on top of that like I
think once we found out that this could
be completely useful and there's not
nothing proprietary about a fairly
simple plugin that like you know just
deploys code to settle GK instances it
was pretty much a non brainer for us to
say like you know let's let's just open
source it but on the whole we do we do
find ourselves embracing a lot of open
standards and open source technologies
like one of the one of the big reasons
for us to sort of buy into GAE was
kubernetes itself being an open standard
as I said like you know we did dabble in
AWS for a long time
a lot of our workloads still run in AWS
I know this is a GCP podcast but but the
thing is like something like kubernetes
would it maybe at some point also allow
us to run workloads in AWS as well as
GCP so it's a fairly open standard it's
portable as long as you're deploying to
containers you know we we should be able
to move our workloads just about
anywhere so that that was one of the
things and the other thing like is we
use a lot of tools from Hoshi Corp
they're all written in go so you know at
least on the on the deployment
automation side of things we're trying
to use a lot of go and a lot of the
Google community is already embracing
open-source it's online and you know
we're often contributing to some of the
hard core products so we do contribute
to terraform we've contributed to a
couple other things we've also
contributed to kubernetes a little bit
so it allows us to also sort of shape
the direction of some of these things as
well I think from my perspective too I
think not only when we're open sourcing
these tools and libraries and things
like that not only is it for us to help
other people and like to be part of the
open source community but from my
perspective it's often helps us make
that tool or that library better I I've
even had like several like Marvin or our
App Engine framework for go like
immediately after we published it even
had some nice contributors from Google
themselves that helped us clean it up
and make it better
I just love random people on the
Internet fixing my things really that's
super cool um you mentioned something
that really sort of side-handle you make
you see gee you're still running a
little bit on AWS
are you still us are running on prem
like are you running your own datacenter
still did you end up finishing that
migration what happened there so no we
haven't been finished a migration yet we
are slated to finish it in the second
quarter of 2018 there's still in the
middle of this huge huge migration from
like our data centers are completely to
the cloud we just finally I think games
we are the first people I think to get
complete public traffic off of AWS in
the past couple weeks now which is been
really nice to give you more context
though like our website is gonna be
hosted on gke as well so if you go to
nytimes.com on your mobile phone you are
hitting a GK GK cluster at that at that
point mmm nice okay so you've mentioned
that you have systems running on Google
cloud platform you have
systems running on Amazon and you also
have systems running on premise now the
question is how do you even monitor all
of these things together so that's a
hard one so because a lot of the lot of
these systems are at very different
states of mature maturity so like we do
have an infrastructure and the systems
team that was already managing our data
center that was actually building things
for our data center and managing things
in our data center so they continue to
exist at this point and will continue to
exist for the foreseeable future because
you know there is a lot of cruft
already out there in our data centers
and a lot of these systems are going to
be forklifted so you know some things
that were running on VMs will probably
continue to run on VMs unless three
platform them to either run on something
like App Engine or containers so so
that's not going away we have we have
the traditional way of maintaining and
managing the systems in our data centers
for AWS there's a little bit more
automation we were using are we still
are using puppet and some or some
configuration management tools to manage
some of some of the systems in Amazon
however on the Google cloud you've sort
of gone all-in and said like you know
we're gonna do kubernetes and we're
gonna do containers and like you know
use drone and like have this have this
faster CI pipeline that allows us to
deploy stuff to Google over time though
we hope that like once we're once you're
fully in in the cloud both Google and
Amazon we can use certain abstractions
that allow us to sort of deploy code
either in Google or Amazon the same way
so one of the ways we've sort of trying
to sum one of the ways that we're trying
to rationalize some of the
infrastructure automation is by using
tools like Hera form which has which has
support for both Google as well as
Amazon you know again one of the choices
with kubernetes as I said was you know
it could run either in Google or Amazon
so as we sort of get more and more
systems in the cloud we want to converge
ways we manage things I think one one
interesting way that we've also try to
manage like part of this transition is
that as services in Google
needing services in Amazon we're
actually running Cloud endpoints in AWS
to expose those services so it's
actually been a nice way for us to get
out of the mentality that everybody's
really defensive via firewalls to
actually expose ourselves to the public
securely using common tools yeah there's
actually a story to that and I don't
know like I know you guys like stories
so like when we first started looking at
Google as I said like you know we we've
traditionally done things a certain way
and we were trying to sort of replicate
our data center or in Amazon so like any
app deployed to Amazon or or our data
center should be indistinguishable from
each other right that was sort of the
philosophy we wanted to go with so we
try to do that with Google we quickly
learned like you know we were we were
basically fighting what was in it in ewa
table like you know google google but
Google like it assumed like a zero trust
network there was no clear notion of
private networking at the time like now
I I know you guys have V pcs and peering
and things like that but like we were
talking about a year ago like goo GCP
didn't have that so there was no easy
way for applications to talk to each
other that existed in different projects
or applications that we were building in
gcpd talk to services that were sitting
in our data center because our data
center was behind like a firewall and we
couldn't like really open open those
ports up so what we started doing was
you know we we found a novel way around
it which was using Google Cloud
endpoints and it allowed us to basically
stand up something in our Amazon
environment using the Cloud endpoints to
service proxy who actually proxy all the
traffic to our data centers from Google
so the teams that were moving at a
faster pace in Google and we're able to
continue building in Google by exposing
some of the underlying services in our
data center and Amazon so that was our
that was our learning like you know like
if teams want to move at their own pace
they can continue to move at their own
pace and let's not try and fight this
all like private networking battle in
Google because you know what let's just
assume zero trust network great so what
you're saying is that you are basically
exposing most of your api's in the open
but you're doing so in yes in a secure
way so I'm curious about how are you
doing that
you doing earth - what the exact
authentication system are you using
there it's mostly like some of the api's
were retrofitted to like have like Auto
token in front of them others that could
sort of be modified a little bit more
are using jwe to secure themselves and
then you know in other cases some api
has already had odd mechanisms built in
which allowed us to just use the proxy
as is and in order to communicate with
each other you are using directly HTTP
with Jason or so rest api is are you
using any kind of G RPC or any other RPC
framework yes and no I mean yes yes
sorry so so for the for the for the
older API is like they were already JSON
over rest we are definitely looking into
G RPC I know someone JPS API is are
already built with G RPC as the
transport mechanism and JP can tell you
a little bit more about that but we also
recently released our publishing
pipeline which is which is basically the
content pipeline from when and when a
reporter and then editor like enter a
story into our CMS it has to basically
go through a whole workflow where it
gets it gets published to a pipeline and
like there are all these consumers that
are reading for like the new edits or
news new updates to a story or or an
entirely new story or any new assets to
a story they're all listening to this
pipeline and the transport mechanism for
the pipeline is G RPC and the pipeline
basically is a large message log sitting
on top of Kafka interesting JP can you
tell us a bit more about your experience
did you or pc8 curious to know sure sure
so like I said most of my services are
running on App Engine where most of our
external traffic is actually coming from
user facing apps and things like that so
most of that mechanism oast of our
authentication and things like that are
just using our existing new york times
user authentication gets interesting
when we start going to this service to
service type of authentication when it
comes to app engine itself we actually
get to rely on that one specific header
that's like the X app ID header and we
could just guarantee that that will sign
the incoming request and we know it's
from
our app kubernetes starts getting fun
with G RPC though we've recently
launched one service where it is a gr PC
service underneath the hood with Cloud
endpoints on the front running on gke
since we are also calling this service
from App Engine we're actually also
leaning on the fun feature that Cloud
endpoints does the HTTP JSON translation
to G RPC for us and that actually kind
of ties back to one of our open source
tools called open API - proto where we
actually describe our API and an open
API spec and generate protobufs that
mimic that open API spec nice with the
HTTP annotations so we can describe our
service in an open API spec translate it
to protobuf handed to Cloud endpoints
and it's exposed in both of those
transport styles quite seamlessly for us
it's kind of nice that's really cool
that's very cool
um as much as I'd love to talk to you
both about all this stuff forever I am
we are running out of time just a little
bit Oh actually quite a lot okay so
before we wrap up is there anything else
that you might want to tell people or to
plug or if there's something
particularly amazing that you've done or
a lesson that you've learnt that you
want to share that we have a minute to
touch on yet is there anything you'd
like to add JP we have you right now
sure for me honestly moving all the
games platform to Google cloud has been
a rather a wonderful experience honestly
we just get to worry about our product
and the problems we should be solving
and not necessarily common
infrastructure problems and the like
it's it's actually been quite nice and
with a team of two people we are able to
do quite a lot excellent deep yourself
what I've learned is I think we want to
build more tooling around being able to
help teams move faster so I think that's
sort of where we want to be like you
want to shift our mentality from being
traditional like systems people like you
know people who manage infrastructure to
people who actually build automation
around the Google infrastructure so I
think that to us has been a very
interesting shift in mentality and I
think there are other organizations who
are trying to make to make this shift I
think that's where like you know they
will find a lot of bang for their buck
and they're in like you know
in terms of investing investing in
Holland I think we made that investment
and I think we're reaping the benefits
at this point yeah I wanted to add one
more thing which is for everyone that is
interested in the New York Times and
everything you do in tech you do have
open dot and why x comm we do which is
basically where we're taking like half
of our cool things of the week yes so so
yeah I just wanted to say so JP Robinson
you read a lot in there but there's also
the people that write not only about go
but like also CSS and stuff like that so
I just wanted to to thank all of the
authors in there because it is really
really cool content awesome yeah thanks
for shout out cool
well yeah thanks to both of you a deep
JP for joining us I really appreciate
you taking the time to hang out with us
and shut about what everything you're
doing in new york times thank you so
much yeah our pleasure thanks thank you
thanks JP and deeply appreciate the
insights on how you guys are using GCP
so mark let's get to the question of the
week
how do you secure communities cluster
what are some best practices to securing
a kubernetes cluster I'm glad you asked
because I am able to reference a
wonderful blog post that has been
written on a DCP blog it's very helpful
yeah from product manager Aaron small
yeah it's great when other people do my
research for me exactly no it's it's
it's actually there's a bunch of
different things that you can do in
terms of security best practices for
your kubernetes cluster I'll definitely
put a link in the show notes to the blog
post so you can read it yourself
there's a few things in here that I
think are particularly good there's a
bunch of stuff in there about using
least privilege service accounts on your
nodes so basically when you set up the
nodes of the new kubernetes cluster you
can give them permission to do certain
things within your cluster you may or
may not want to do that so if there's no
necessary reason for say a particular
node to access pops up for example or
Google Cloud Storage maybe there's no
reason for them to do that then you
might want to turn that off
if there are no reason for them to be
accessing other compute engine instances
you can set up firewall rules to do that
sort of thing other nice stuff in there
there is a kubernetes web UI you can
actually turn that off there's a command
line here the turn off the UI the UI has
administrative access to do pretty much
anything so if somebody gets access to
it which they shouldn't you can turn
that off that means that then you can
lock down how things happen inside your
communities cluster and it's also worth
noting
that the attribute based access control
was disabled by default in kubernetes
1.8 in that gave a lot more access to
communities now our back which is the
role based access control was released
as beta in communities 1.6 is now the
default in 1.8 and there's commands in
here if you want to turn that off for
existing if you want to turn off that
that attribute based access control
anyway go for our back our back is the
one you want that is the one you want so
basically you can turn everything off
and cap it all to keep it from from
anybody accessing things you you're not
even using exactly yeah so use our back
our backs good and also if you want to
get to enter the nitty-gritty you can
also do cluster Network policy so you
can basically do firewall rules for pods
defining how they can talk to the
outside world or between themselves as
well and that's another way you can also
look things down but definitely read the
blog post it's well worth your time and
it'll give you some ideas on how you can
get things look down and more secure
great ok so mark are you going anywhere
fun for December December is still going
to Miggs so I'll be in Montreal as of
next week Montreal international games
summit that's where all day you'll be at
nips oh you're still at nips what are
you doing right so this week I'm at nips
and I am basically here through the week
and at the end of the week there's
actually an event that I'm gonna be
attending which I'm looking forward to
and that's specifically a event for
black in AI which is an organization
that is fostering basically a community
of researchers that identify
self-identify as black or and/or their
allies yes
so it's an event that's going to be
happening at the Marriott Renaissance
Long Beach Hotel for anybody who's in
the area and that wants to come please
come check it out and that's December
the 8th I'm reading this right that is
December 8th on Friday between 1 & 6
fantastic and we'll have a link on the
blog cool all right Ellen well thank you
once again for joining me for yet
another episode of the podcast thanks
mark so I think next week is the full
like we're finally going to have an
interview together yeah we're actually
doing an interview together next week
yeah next week is the wrap the
end-of-year review too so we bring back
friends esque and we're gonna go through
and talk about kind of what have been
the popular episodes for the year as
well as you some personal favorites it's
a good episode I know how it goes
definitely awesome all right thank you
very much to all that listeners and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]